l'actualité de ce samedi 21 juillet
c'est aussi le sommet du g8 à gênes en
italie
la mort hier d'un jeune extrémiste
italien tué d'une balle en pleine tête
par la police n'a pas empêché de
nouveaux incidents cet après midi en
marge de la grande manifestation anti
mondialisation ont fait le point tout de
suite avec pascal golomer et gilles
jacquier la manifestation se voulait
massive avec deux cent mille personnes
l'objectif est atteint mais les
organisateurs n'ont pu éviter les
violences
al'approche de la zone rouge quelques
centaines d'éléments de plus veulent
forcer le passage
ceux qu'on surnomme le bloc noir
les forces de l'ordre les postes
d'abord à coups de grenades lacrymogènes
le cortège lui tente d'avancer malgré
tout sur une avenue à l'écart les
services d'ordre
à chaque noël canalisent la foule mais
les forces de l'ordre veulent repousser
alors les agresseurs mouvement de
panique et de colère chez les
manifestants
ceci dit avec plus de 100 villes à 300
milles et ça donnera un bon coup d'arrêt
à cette focalisation alors la journée
gâchée n'est pas gâcher la journée
réussie les gens sont pacifistes et gens
manifester il résiste pas ma la
provocation sans doute est réussi mais
c'est fini à 15h la violence l'a emporté
l'étape de l'ordre veulent ont refusé
tout le monde sans distinction
ce qui reste du cortège doit faire demi
tour chacun s'enfuie comme il peut
les militaires ils auront même sur la
plage en contrebas de la route
chasser le moindre manifestants
ici tout se passera bien
tél
[Applaudissements]
réponse dans la violence il nous à
grenade ans qu'on est venus
pacifiquement mais à quelques mètres de
là certains n'ont pu éviter la charge
d'essence élan
ils marchaient dans le cortège
tout simplement
le premier a soif et de nombreux blessés
parmi les militants les plus pacifiques
un nouvel affrontement va avoir lieu
avec les éléments les plus violents qui
avaient réussi à s'échapper sur la plage
nouvelles charges nouvelles bombes
lacrymogènes nouvelles violences les
forces de l'ordre poursuivent encore
ceux qui l'ont agressé les manifestants
pacifiques
eux n'auront pu défiler que quelques
minutes ils ne retiendront de leur
séjour à gènes que ces scènes de
guérillas en bord de mer